only on CBS this morning we have new
details about the mysterious death of a
border patrol agent in Texas President
Trump promised back in November to bring
the killers of agent Rogelio Martinez to
justice he used the death to a new cause
for a wall on the Mexico border but the
FBI now believes that Martinez's death
was indeed an accident
David beg no travelled to southern Texas
to uncover what federal investigators
believe actually happened to him David
good morning jail good morning this all
happened near the town of Van Horne
that is about a hundred miles east of
the city of El Paso about 30 miles from
the us-mexico border
now the FBI poured its resources into
this investigation they did more than
650 interviews and 26 searches and while
the President and other politicians use
the death to make a political point we
have learned the FBI believes what
happened was an accident and not a crime
that is the culvert where agent Rogelio
Martinez was found dying in November
it's located along a quiet stretch of
interstate 10 near the us-mexico border
the area looks like it's in the middle
of nowhere
Martinez was responding to a tripped
sensor along a known drug smuggling
route he radioed for backup a law
enforcement source tells CBS News
Martinez then parked on the eastbound
side of Interstate 10 he turned off his
headlights and kept his emergency lights
off so potential smugglers wouldn't see
him coming it was a moonless night there
are no streetlights out here so really
the only light that you have would be a
flashlight or the headlights of a
passing vehicle according to our source
agent Martinez who was not using night
vision equipment ran across the
eastbound lanes of i-10 through the
grass divider and then across the
westbound lanes and ran right off the
edge of a culvert that had no guardrail
or barrier to stop him I'm six one so if
I go to walk into one of the culverts
you know put my hand here the estimation
is it's about a nine or a ten foot drop
if the agent were to fall off of it
according to our source agent Stephen
garland who arrived right after Martinez
may have made the same mistake running
across the interstate and right off that
edge the FBI suspects garland fell off
at a different point
his blood was found about 22 feet from
agent Martinez's body a border patrol
dispatcher was able to make contact with
agent garland after his fall despite his
injuries Garland was able to get back to
his vehicle and turn on his emergency
lights at that time garland told a
dispatcher something to the effect of we
ran into a culvert or I ran into a
culvert or I think I ran into a culvert
now the dispatcher wrote in his log
thinks they ran into a culvert the FBI
found no other footprints at the scene
no defensive wounds on either man or any
DNA belonging to anyone other than the
two ages are you open to the possibility
that maybe this was an accident
no that make sense to you it's been
three months since agent Martinez died
and his fiancee Angie Ochoa is not
convinced by the FBI's theory she says
Martinez's injuries were too severe to
have been caused by a fall
she's also suspicious because toxicology
tests found a pain medication
buuuut Alba tall in his system somebody
convinced him to take that medication I
think to make it seem like it was an
accident you're not suggesting he was
drugged at this point I think it was
probably given to him intentionally even
in a normal dose sometimes there can be
some impairment of ability to function
but a very little impairment we asked
forensic pathologist dr. Michael Baden
to look at Martinez his autopsy report
which states that he died of blunt force
injuries to the head but classifies the
manner of death as undetermined this is
all very typical for a fall and not for
a fight CBS News has learned agent
garland suffered multiple broken
vertebrae and had a brain bleed the FBI
believes he has amnesia
and had nothing to do with aja
Martinez's death they found no evidence
of animosity or a conflict between him
and agent Martinez
despite the FBI's findings union
officials at the National Border Patrol
Council have called it a heinous attack
and they refused to back down from that
this group of drug smugglers attacked
him and ambushed him it looks like he
was literally beaten to death
so no smugglers were ever found we asked
the White House for comment on this
story and they told us no we called
union officials 40 times we left 15
voicemails we sent ten emails and five
text messages they finally got back to
us and told us that the people who were
authorized to talk would not be
available what a mystery the whole thing
so what is the local sheriff's office
thing well the sheriff told me look we
got the call as an accident he said
David that's why we responded with our
medical bags because if we'd have
thought it was an attack we would have
responded with assault rifles thank you
we followed up on that story you got to
feel for family members who are still
very skeptical absolutely but David
while you're here it's always good to
have you at the table congratulations by
the way it's an order being awarded the
prestigious George Polk Journalism Award
for public service recognizes of course
all of your work in Puerto Rico where I
think at one point weren't they calling
you the patron saint Rico two months
covering the dedication there we did
more than 40 days and I have to tell you
there were 35 people who were with me
who made it possible to do that
reporting this is a team effort it's not
a me award I will leave the gratitude
train and saying thank you we are we are
very grateful you exposed a lot of what
was really going on well thank you
grateful to you David st. work Congrats
thank you